AINSLEY: OUTRAGE IN THE NATIONS
CAPITAL AS NATIONAL GUARD
MEMBERS FORESTS TO REST DURING
THEIR BREAKS INSIDE PARKING
GARAGES.
STEVE: FLORIDA GOVERNOR RON
DESANTIS ANNOUNCED HE ORDERED
HIS STATE’S TROOPS TO COME
HOME.
BRIAN: THE GOVERNOR JOINS US
FROM SAINT PETE, GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING.
BRIAN: A LOT OF PEOPLE LOOKS AT
THOSE IMAGES OF NATIONAL
GUARDSMEN IN THE NATIONS
CAPITAL, TO MAKE SURE THE
INAUGURATION WAS SECURE,
SLEEPING ON THE FLOOR OF THE
CAPITAL AND SOMEONE KICKED THEM
OUT AND SAID GO SLIP -- SLEEP
IN THE GARAGE.
YOU WERE INFURIATED AND THAT IS
WHY YOU OFFICIALLY CALLED
PEOPLE BACK LAST NIGHT AND IT
WAS ANNOUNCED THIS MORNING.
>> THESE FOLKS ARE SOLDIERS.
THEY SERVED OUR COUNTRY, THE
STATE OF FLORIDA AFTER NATURAL
DISASTERS, THEY ARE SERVING
RIGHT NOW HELPING WITH
VACCINATING SENIOR CITIZENS,
THEY ARE NOT NANCY PELOSI’S
SERVANT AND THIS IS ON THE BACK
END OF THEM TRYING TO
INVESTIGATE THE BACKGROUND OF
OUR GUARDSMEN.
FLORIDA, WE DID NOT LET THEM GO
-- IT WAS TOTALLY
INAPPROPRIATE, VERY
DISRESPECTFUL SO THIS IS A HALF
COCKED MISSION AT THIS POINT
AND THE IMPORTANT THING IS TO
BRING THEM HOME.
>> THERE ARE SO MANY NEW
YORKERS TEMPORARILY LIVING IN
FLORIDA, THEY WANT TO BE IN THE
SUNSHINE.
YOU ARE OPENING EVERYTHING UP.
THEY ARE LOVING IT IN FLORIDA.
YOU ALLOW PEOPLE TO GET
VACCINES THERE.
BRIAN: FLY FROM CANADA, SOUTH
AMERICA, THERE ARE A LOT OF
THOSE.
>> THAT IS TOTALLY NOT TRUE.
1.3 MILLION REPORTED VACCINE
SHOTS, HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
MORE, 97% FULL-TIME FLORIDA
RESIDENTS.
WE HAVE PEOPLE OF OUR PART-TIME
RESIDENTS, YOU LIVE HERE OVER
THE WINTER.
LET THEM HAVE DOCTORS HERE,
THERE IS NO VACCINE TOURISM.
HOSPITALS ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
ENGAGE IN VACCINE TOURISM.
IF SOMEONE DIDN’T FOLLOW THE
RULES THAT IS SOMETHING WE DEAL
WITH.
WE ARE PUTTING OUR SENIORS
FIRST AND PUTTING FLORIDA
SENIORS FIRST.
BRIAN: THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
VACCINATED LEADING THE NATION,
THE PERCENTAGE OF VACCINE
ADMINISTERED, 65 PERSONS,
500,000 INDIVIDUALS IN THE
STATE RECEIVED THE VACCINE.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING DIFFERENTLY
THAT IS ALLOWING YOU TO
VACCINATE THE POPULATION?
>> IT IS BETTER THAN THAT.
WE ARE REPORTING 840,000
SENIORS HAVE RECEIVED THE SHOT
BUT THE REPORTING, WE REALLY
BELIEVE TODAY IS THE DAY WE
WILL DO OUR ONE MILLIONTH
SENIOR IN THE STATE OF FLORIDA.
I HAVE A WORLD WAR II VETERAN
YOU WILL SEE GET THE SHOT.
HE’S 100 YEARS OLD, A GREAT
GUY.
WHAT WE DID IS WE PUT SENIORS
FIRST.
THIS IS SOMETHING WE NEED TO
FOCUS ON, THE 65 AND UP
POPULATION, YOUNG WORK THE --
WORKERS GETTING ANOTHER
STATEMENT I WANT TO PROTECT OUR
VULNERABLE.
THAT IS WHAT WE ARE DOING.
IN ALL 67 COUNTIES, WORKING
WITH PHARMACIES, HOSPITALS AND
IF YOU DOUBLE MY VACCINE
ALLOTMENT NEXT WEEK I WOULD BE
ABLE TO DO DOUBLE THE VACCINE.
AINSLEY: WHY AREN’T WE GETTING
THE VACCINE?
NOT ENOUGH TIME?
>> THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WHEN
THEY GET THEM THEY SEND THEM
BUT I THOUGHT WE WOULD BE
GETTING MORE BY NOW, 266,000
THE WEEK.
LAST WEEK MONDAY THROUGH
SUNDAY, 405,000 SHOTS.
I AM NOW DOING MORE SHOTS IN A
WEEK AND IF WE SEE INCREASES IN
SUPPLY, YOU ACTUALLY SEE FEWER
VACCINES ON A DAILY BASIS BUT
WE HAVE ONE RIGHT HERE.
ARE YOU READY TO DO THAT?
>> 100 YEARS OLD ARMY OR CORE
VETERAN.
>> HE IS A WORLD WAR II
VETERAN, 100 YEARS OLD.
HE HAS HAD A REMARKABLE CAREER
OF SERVICE TO OUR COUNTRY AND
THE STATE OF FLORIDA.
HE WAS A STATE SENATOR HERE.
HE KNEW CHARLES LINDBERGH, BUZZ
ALDRIN, JOE DIMAGGIO, PRESIDENT
TRUMAN, REAGAN, AN AMERICAN
HERO, ALMOST 100 YEARS OLD AND
HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET THE
VACCINE AND WE ARE EXCITED.
AND WE DO BELIEVE THIS IS THE
ONE MILLIONTH SENIOR WHICH THE
REPORTING WILL BEAR OUT OVER
THE NEXT COUPLE DAYS.
STEVE: HE CAN’T HEAR US.
>> I CAN ASK HIM A QUESTION.
STEVE: ASK HOW IT FELT.
>> HOW DOES THAT FEEL?
>> DIDN’T FEEL A THING.
[APPLAUSE]
>> THIS GUY STILL HAS SOME
GUNS.
THIS IS A HANDSOME INDIVIDUAL.
STEVE: PANTHERA THANKS TO HENRY
FOR HIS SERVICE WAS WHAT DOES
IT MEAN TO HIM TO GET THE
VACCINE?
>> HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT?
>> HOW HAPPY WE ARE TO DELIVER
THE NUMBER ONE STATE OF THE
UNION, THE NUMBER ONE GOVERNOR
IN THE UNION.
AINSLEY: COULD YOU ASK HIM
BEING 100, HAS BEEN HUNKERED
DOWN FOR THE LAST YEAR TO
MINIMIZE THE EXPOSURE, YOU
NEVER KNOW WHO HAS GOT IT.
>> HOW DO YOU HANDLE WHEN
COVID-19 HIT, HAVE YOU BEEN
ISOLATING?
WHAT DID YOU DO?
>> C FRIENDS AND FAMILY, THINGS
ARE NOT NORMAL.
WE HAVE BEEN VERY CLOSE TO
NORMAL.
>> I THINK A LOT OF FLORIDIANS,
THIS IS REAL BUT HE HAS LIVED A
FULL LIFE AND HE’S GOING TO
KEEP LIVING IN THIS VACCINE
HELPS THEM DO MORE.
AINSLEY: I WONDER IF HE EVER
EXPERIENCED ANYTHING LIKE THIS.
>> WHAT DID HE EXPERIENCE?
HE SAID HE DIDN’T FEEL A THING.
THANK HENRY FOR HIS SERVICE AND
SHOWING THE WORLD.
>> THANKS FOR DOING THIS.
HE SAID THANKS, GUYS.
BRIAN: I BELIEVE YOU OWE IS
THAT GREAT ENDORSEMENT.